we're entering the area now in the
crosshairs of russia's territorial
ambitions the heart of the donbass
region in eastern ukraine
it's here that the russians are now
focusing and where there's evidence of
fresh attacks all along our route
as we travel in we see reinforcements
arriving all the time as the ukrainians
send extra troops and military hardware
to fight the russians off
this is one of the latest hits in the
past 24 hours the russians have hit a
volley of strikes in towns like that
moved in eastern ukraine and just 30
kilometers down that road is newly
captured russian territory as they're
trying to claim more and more land in
the donbass region
but the russian bombs are finding new
targets every day the towns around here
are being hit day and night
the targets in the centre of heavily
built up residential areas this was a
factory providing heating for around 10
000 people in the district
there are a number killed in this attack
amongst them a soldier and others who
had a narrow escape
this soldier was in the middle of
sending an audio note to his friend when
the explosion happened
it was a few hundred meters away he
tells us minutes afterwards he's filming
himself with the smoke behind him to the
same friend
what do you think the russians are
trying to
they're targeting civilians he says
they're just trying to make civilians
panic
the ukrainian successes in fighting off
the russians from kievan hakeev has
meant the invaders have upped the tempo
with increased savagery to try to
wrestle control of donbass they haven't
counted on the people here
they may capture territory but they
can't make us ukrainians their slaves
anatoly tells us we'll never sing to the
russian tune it's impossible just
impossible
the residents clear up their shattered
homes with a battle-hardened weariness
now
they've endured nearly three months of
this trauma and turmoil
why should i be afraid she says i just
don't want the things landing in my
house and i don't want them to hit
people
[Music]
but people are dying and families are
suffering terribly
every person who dies at home in their
town or on the battlefield in donbass
like yuri leaves behind broken-hearted
relatives
yuri was 32 years old among the mourners
is his 13 year old daughter darina
another family utterly devastated by
this war
so many of his friends turned out for
his send-off
and saying goodbye never gets any easier
i want to hug you just one more time
she's crying
mothers aren't meant to bury their
children
[Music]
fellow soldiers try to give them the
respect they feel a fallen comrade
deserves
[Applause]
they know there's a chance they'll face
the same fate but they'll leave here to
continue defending donbass anyway
and to those who loved him and will miss
him yuri dies a hero
is it worth it
no alina says no it's not worth his
death
because my child is gone just suddenly
my child's gone and i'm so sad
but he died a hero she goes on
russia may have scaled down its military
ambitions the tactics and focus may have
altered but for those still being killed
and terrorized it doesn't feel much
different
alex crawford sky news in the donbass
region ukraine